hi welcome back to app inventors hour of
code I'm Emily and I'm Shay in our last
video we showed you how to make the talk
to me app you push a button and the
phone talks to you so cool well we had
to start somewhere I'm ready to get to
the cool stuff okay now we're going to
extend the talk to me app so that it
responds when you shake it and also set
a user can put in their own text stop
shaking me cool enough for you now I see
endless opportunities I grew on a run
and get constant encouragement great so
we're going to get started and the great
thing is this only takes a couple of
minutes because app and better makes it
really easy is your phone talking to you
well hang on because it's about to get
even more fun we left off with our talk
to me app in the blocks editor right now
we need to go back into the designer to
add another component we want to extend
talk to me so that the phone speaks when
you shake it to do that we need an
accelerometer component click on the
sensors drawer and drag out an
accelerometer sensor this is another non
visible component so it drops down to
the bottom of the screen that's all we
need for right now go back over to the
blocks editor as you develop your apps
you'll move back and forth between the
designer and the blocks editor quite a
bit we now need a block for when the
phone is shaking this is also called an
event handler drag out the when
accelerometer sensor 1 dot shaking block
so when this event is triggered that's
when the phone is being shaken what do
we want to happen then we want the phone
to talk to us right so we already know
the blocks that handle that the same
blocks that we have inside the button
click event here's a cool shortcut that
will help you program in App Inventor
even more quickly you can copy and paste
blocks click on the purple
text-to-speech block hit the key
combination on your computer for copy
just like you would do with text
and then hit the key combination for
paste voila you have a new set of the
text to speech and text blocks drag this
new set down into the accelerometer
shaking event block if you had any
trouble copying and pasting blocks
that's okay you can also drag out new
blocks from the drawers on the left
remember we got the text to speech speak
block from text to speech and we got the
plaintext block from the built-in text
drawer so right now the phone will speak
out loud if you shake it but wouldn't it
be much more fun if the phone says
something about being shaken let's put
in a funny phrase I'm going to type in
stop shaking me okay try it out pick up
your phone and shake it stop so our app
is pretty cool right but wait there's
one more thing to add imagine sharing
this app with your friends don't you
think it would be a lot more fun if they
could tell the phone what to say to set
this up go back into the designer go to
the user interface drawer and pull out a
text box let's rearrange that a bit and
put the button under the text box okay
guess what back to the blocks click on
text box and look at the blocks it has
we now want to change what happens when
the button is clicked instead of saying
a fixed phrase we want the app to say
whatever the user has typed into the
text box scroll all the way down to the
green blocks that we call getters and
setters because they allow you to get
and set the properties of the component
you want to get the text that has been
typed into the box so you need the
getter block for textbox1.text put that
block inside the win button click event
block to do this you have to throw away
the old text block and then click this
new text box text block in its place try
your app out again when you click in the
blank text box on your phone your
keyboard will come up and you can type
in whatever you want then click talk to
me and see what happens however there
are some cool ways to extend this app
see the written tutorial for some great
ideas for making it even better if you
had any trouble with this tutorial you
can view the written version on our
website stop stop stop oh man we made a
real app that's kind of annoying you
mean it oh right well you're gonna have
a ball with our next step because we're
going to show you how to make a ball
roll around the screen when you fling it
with your finger can't wait